you're sort of giving birth to something
else a really incredible initiative this
sweater that i am wearing which i am so
yay from shine the light on right here
in canada tell us a little bit about
that
yeah so we were approached and asked if
we wanted to participate and work with
shine the light on to create one of
these limited edition collaborations
that they you know that they do so well
with people like us um to raise money
for a great cause and specifically they
came to us asking if we wanted to raise
money to build this or help build this
photography academy at this place called
variety boys and girls club here in los
angeles in this incredible neighborhood
uh boyle heights um that's historically
pretty underserved and this organization
is just doing incredible things for the
kids and the families in this community
from very young ages
um all the way up to prepping them for
college and afterwards scholarships
mentorships and then also you know
grocery deliveries to family especially
during covet when a lot of kids aren't
getting
food and uh it's it's just really really
incredible that they've been working in
this community for 73 years so amazing
so they came to us to work with variety
well they have all these different
programs that the kids decide they want
the kids say well we want to do this and
the amazing people there go let's figure
out how to do it so they have like a
great music program they're teaching
them how to dj and they bring cool dj's
swim garden rock climb and so they came
to us and said well the kids have
expressed a real interest in a
photography academy to which i this is
what i love to do other than acting
that's like what i spend all my time
doing and and it's a real passion of
mine so the idea that i could play any
role in helping them raise the money to
make that dream come true was like tell
us where to sign we were totally on
board and then of course shine the light
on and what they do is so amazing they
helped us design these they got us
together with designers and we threw
ideas back and forth and we came up with
this
line and now we're happy to introduce it
and send it off into the world and a
hundred percent of the proceeds go to
variety boys and girls club so they go
that's so exciting i really couldn't
believe that when china like on said
that to us 100
100 of the proceeds go to building this
photography academy it was just a
no-brainer for us to sign on yeah i have
probably four of their tracksuits and
legitimately have worn them back-to-back
for three years their stuff quality is
incredible so cozy
they're so cozy they're so great so talk
about the design and and and really how
that came to be it's kind of a combo of
soup and pretty little liars talk about
that
yeah well i mean i the really exciting
thing about shine the light on was that
you know we have this incredible both of
us have these incredible fan bases um
from students and from pretty little
liars and we always are looking for ways
to engage our fans and to mobilize you
know them to do great things and also to
give back to them and say thank you for
being fans of ours so i think when they
came to us and said
what should be on the sweatshirts
it was you know we wanted to pay homage
to pretty little liars as you have on
yours and you know you can get a number
of different colors and different styles
um so we have the classic shush
and then um
suits we have i'm currently sporting
this one because i realized i really
wanted to start actually i was showing
off my suits fandom we have our
autographs on them which yeah which is
pretty fun
and then we did this one which is just a
camera that says the word variety in it
because we wanted to you know make sure
and remind people of what this was all
for and then that you know it started
with the main part is we came in and
said we wanted to do like a single line
drawing because we've been really we
have a friend who does them and she's
amazing at it so the last couple of
years we've just become obsessed with
like single line drawings so we threw
that at them and came up with these as
single line drawings and that was it
yeah
wow what impact did art have on your
lives growing i've got a little girl who
is just
lives eats breeds art it's just
something she was born it just seems
she's just hungry for it all the time
was that something for both of you was
that the way you were when you were
younger
yeah you know uh i was a pretty
uncomfortable anxious little kid and so
when i discovered the arts it was like
oh school doesn't have to be just the
stuff that kind of scares me which is
math and science which i was okay at but
it always felt very heady
um there was this other part of school
where suddenly i felt like i could be
myself like whatever was going on with
me was welcome and it was my job to like
figure that out and express it
and that was just like magical to me and
obviously we both you know
pursued careers in the arts um so we've
become
you know pretty taken with that
lifestyle but especially as a young kid
when you're in that zone of not really
sure what you're supposed to do or where
you fit or who you are in the world i
found that i like kind of became most
myself once i stepped into art rooms
whether it was visual art or
specifically obviously dramatic arts and
doing theater
i suddenly like became who i really
wanted to be and i think it has
something to do with like having the
freedom to express your situation your
feelings your thoughts whatever you're
going through
and specifically for me for photography
uh you know acting is a great art form i
love it but you really have to do it
with other people like it's not
something you can go home and do in your
basement or you know spend the weekend
just like acting by yourself like it's a
very community based thing which i love
but photography for me became my thing i
could do when i wasn't getting acting
opportunities or when i wasn't on set or
wasn't working on a play it was
something that i could just literally
take the day instead of watching tv i
could go shoot photos and i could learn
more about photos and i could buy a new
camera and i could play learn learn
about using film and developing and
printing so it's become like
the way that i keep myself creative when
i when i can't be doing the thing that i
love to do most which is act
so it marks uh
what five years since pretty little
liars finale
where
i'm gone and have you heard anything
about the pretty little liars
reboot
gosh uh where's the time gone is a great
question that i ask myself every day and
um and then have i heard anything about
the pretty little liars reboot no i
i don't know anything about it i know
that uh bailey madison is gonna be
starring in it and i got to hang out
with her we did some
work uh in washington dc when i think
she was like 14 years old and a fan of
the original pretty little liars so the
fact that she is carrying on the torch
in any way to me is really cool and um i
just can't wait to see what they do with
the story i have no idea what it's going
to be like
amazing and taurean um any chance we'll
get you directing the reboot
that would be super cool i've i've told
them that would be really fun i know
that they're closing up their first
season so maybe that'll be something we
could put together for their second
season
amazing um and patrick um suits is going
to the middle east what do you think
about that
i had no idea you just saw it's the
first time i've heard that i just saw
that on instagram
they're going to the middle east
like like i'm going to the middle east
like right now or you can go
they're making a version of suits in the
middle east yeah what do you think i'm
all for it i think that's great
i i mean i think it's amazing that our
show has i've been shocked and surprised
since the first season of suits you know
i i thought our show was good i was
proud of what we were doing but the idea
that it would be so universally loved
and like appeal to people throughout all
cultures and you know that we would just
like in so many countries people were
just obsessed with suits and i still
travel the world and like be in malaysia
and people just going crazy for it be
like really just a bunch of lawyers in
new york city i don't i didn't quite
understand
that it would be that widely loved so
the fact that it's going to the middle
east i you know is sort of surprising
but i guess after all these years not
really i think it's great i wish them
all the best